I continue with the concept of the
eternally asked question what should I
play in the opening and for these
evenings lecture I was concentrating on
a black defense to 1.e4 and I mentioned
that there are two types of Defense's
the first type is where the e4 pawn is
attacked the second type is where you
let the e4 pawn stay where it is and it
was the second type of defense that I'm
suggesting for this evenings a class
which is to play the accelerated dragon
and that comes from the Sicilian defense
c5 Knight f3 knight c6 d4 takes takes g6
and now this is the crossroad that white
faces and for a lot of players they are
very perturbed when their opponents play
c4 and initiate what we call the Morosi
bind okay
so the idea of the Monocacy bind is as
you can imagine with these pawns on c4
as well as efore to control the d5
square and make it exceptionally hard
for black to ever gain a measure of
counter play alright after the move c4
however don't be upset like okay man you
know you get to play c4 that's just I'll
live with it you live with it I feel
pretty good actually when my opponent
plays c4 against me in this position why
because after the move c4 I know you're
not going to Castle queenside if this
move c4 basically tells me I now know
the address of your king your king is
going to go King site which I guess is a
very good thing I know I already know I
have never had any doubts in my mind my
king is definitely going King site it's
not going Queen site okay so after c4
the line of play is pretty
straightforward and forcing the Bishop
g7 attacks the knight the bishop
develops defending the knight the night
comes out attacks
um the pawn on e4 the knight comes out
and attack and defends the pawn on e4
now funnily enough this too is a kind of
a crossroads position and Black has two
main moves by far by far the most common
move is the move castles and it's the
move I would recommend however in this
position there was a move that was
really championed by one of my heroes
then Larson bent lark bent you could
always count on bent to stir up the pot
and make things spicy so if you're
playing against a player don't we all
play against opponents who you think we
should beat then we could spice it up
right from the start we spice things up
with the move Knight g4 holy cow
what kind of move is that doesn't the
knight on g4 isn't it in capture to the
queen we go Queen tags oh no because the
queen is defending the knight on d4 so
can black army can white play Knight
takes c6 and win a piece no he cannot
after the move Knight takes III knight
takes D 8 Knight takes D 1 rook takes D
1 King takes D 8 the material is even
you may say yes mister Sarah 1 but I've
I've lost my right to castle it's true
it's true it's a lament it's you can't
have everything in life but this is
actually a good position for black
because this kind of middle game ending
is actually black has the two bishops
and if black is really greedy black
could also consider the move Bishop
takes c3 check B take c3 and only now
King takes c7 so by eliminating the
night that was on c3 I prepare nice
little home for my King on c7 once my
King gets to c7 I don't have to worry
about any Knight checks and furthermore
these pawns these double pawns on the C
file are actually two blacks benefit so
this position is actually favorable for
black by far so I'm really willing to
take the risk
so this moved Knight g4 dust spice
things up and most grandmasters settle
for the following variation Queen takes
g4 Knight takes d4 we'll notice that now
that our knight occupies the square d4
it does threaten Knight see to check
forking the King on e 1 and the rook on
a one most grandmasters play the move
Queen D 1 and again it brings us to a
crossroad in a game I had with black
against Boris goko in a US Championship
I supported my knight on d4 with a movie
v that game was a draw
but with hindsight I would probably like
to take that move back and this is only
25 years later right excuse me mr.
arbiter
can I have my move back yeah
what bent Larsen liked to play is the
move Knight d6 okay so what his idea was
is if we look at the moon look at the
night on e6 it doesn't make a very good
impression does it I mean what does this
Knight do on e6 well in the first place
it kind of stays in a way of our Bishop
not that our bishop had an open diagonal
to begin with but Ben's idea was very
clear he wanted to play Bishop takes c3
check B take c3
b6 and come with his bishop and his rook
to attack this pawn on c4 or his other
idea was that he wanted to play b6
Bishop d7 now he's got the double
fianchetto both bishops on the long
diagonal and with his pawn here his
bishop here he move his king and then
play f7 f5 chipping away at White Center
in this fashion and this position is so
unexplored amongst amateur players and
even amongst professionals it's very
easy for the first player to go wrong
unfortunately in the case of bent his
most celebrated a game in this variation
I think was against Petrosyan and
Petrosyan killed him so it does have its
risks shall we say Ben please I have a
position with ninety six three times
what was against the gentlemen who was
just on I see Sierra canceling okay from
Canada's your subtle even probably lives
in for you
consummates yes and I had a draw were my
own head force me and I play d5 once
would you play against cool right a peak
ribbon saw in the US Championship yes
they know yeah so in your experience
you're saying that you actually like to
move ninety six you kind of think right
and you get different types of middle
games who drew a car phenomenal 79
Larsen V car bombers right right and
again this variation has been championed
by many that I think bent Larsen is the
guy who really brought the whole
variation to my attention and again the
point is is that this Bishop is actually
sitting here really very very nicely on
this diagonal it does have threats and
it does do double duty when our king
castles it's a wonderful guard if you
will for the king so this is the first
opportunity where where black stands at
a crossroad and the move Knight g4 is
actually a rather good move
deserving of attention as they would say
I would suggest the move castles and
after castles we get Bishop e2 I believe
as the main move
take this knight Knight takes d4 Bishop
takes d4 d6 all of these moves have been
played I want to say hundreds of times
but that may be exaggerating but I do
want to say that this position is very
very well known okay
and now we have a crossroads from blacks
point of view black has to ask myself a
question essentially this night is good
this bishop is good this rook is good
this King is good the question that
black needs to ask himself is what does
he want to do with this bishop what does
he want to do with his mission on the
one hand he can put his bishop on e6 and
potentially attack the pawn on c4 on the
other hand he can put his Bishop on d7
followed by his bishop on c6 and attack
the pawn on e4 one of the things that
black usually doesn't do is he usually
doesn't want to play the move b7 b6 -
because in many cases once we put our
pawn on d6 we end up encouraging our
opponent to play and move a four a five
something that is actually favorable to
the first player I the different
grandmasters have different approaches a
lot of grandmasters prefer the first
option putting their bishop on e6
followed by queen a5 followed by rook on
f8 to c8
that's the first option I actually think
something deserves to be said for the
second option Bishop d7 okay so at the
moment things are pretty kind of
balanced black has his fair share of the
center he has good development for his
pieces he's got a safe King so from all
of our checkpoints checkmarks from the
opening has been okay from White's point
of view why does a little bit happier
because he's got a pretty good grip over
the d5 square one good square control
doesn't make a decisive advantage or
anything like that so I would like my
audience to recommend a move for white
in this position if you had the white
pieces what would you do
put you to don't all shout out a one
here again I feel the birthing process
okay what would you do Julian again
sorry bishop
Edgar three so this is a kind of a
voluntary retreat I haven't done Bishop
David three I beg your pardon Bishop
David three okay so your motivation
behind the move Bishop d3 is you think
that my bishop will pardon me White's
Bishop is a little bit more effective on
d3 and that maybe it gives room for the
Queen and you do add extra protection
for efore but on the other hand it's a
whole tempo right I mean it's you always
gotta weigh those things young man did
you have a suggestion no okay so one of
the things that black is what we like to
say that the opening has three of them
the opening the chasse has three stages
right the opening middle gate endgame
probably you've attended enough of my
lectures to know what I consider when
does the middlegame begin right when has
the opening over to my way of thinking
the opening is over
when a player connects his rooks it's
that simple okay and makes it very easy
to to understand when it opening is over
when a middle game starts although it's
not that vital to understand why the
difference when you're in the opening
you know what you're trying to do
control the center develop your pieces
safe King when you're in the middle game
the criteria changes when you're in the
middle game you're trying to develop a
plan trying to create
a long-term idea so after the move
Bishop d3 black in these types of
positions of the mobarak C bind
invariably plays the move Queen a5 and
the moment there's no Queen a5 is played
what do we do we connect our rooks so
the openings over it's that simple so
after we move our Queen to a5 what black
is trying to do is black does not let me
repeat myself black does not want to
play the movie 75 although you may be
tempted to play such a move because you
think oh when I play the move e5 I
attack my opponents Bishop and I gain a
tempo I get to develop my pawn to e5 for
free in fact you're injuring your in
your own position because after you play
the move e5 first of all you've created
a weakness on d6 secondly you've closed
your own Bishop on the diagonal so
blacks play in this position again we
call it the maroc C bind is not geared
towards the center strangely enough it's
geared toward Queen side Black's idea is
to bring this rook on f8 to see a play a
7 a 6 and B 7 B 5 attacking this pawn on
c4 so Julian well how would you continue
your concept Knight
David five correct did I get that one
right
okay so 95 now you should almost send me
a letter of thanks that your intention
was to play Knight d5 and my move Queen
a5 invited to you to go 95 so that you
can capture my pawn on e7 but I'm a
crafty fellow I've been around you know
I've seen the world you know I mean I've
been around you know yeah and I'm not
that easy to fall for trick so I will of
course take your knight and not allow
you to capture my pawn with check curse
the thought that I should lose upon the
check mmm
your Bishop on d4 is hanging you will
take it yes bishop takes to yourself now
what Julian is trying to achieve
literally Karpov made a career a living
career yeah he must have he must have
become a twenty eight hundred by
achieving these types of middle game
positions where his pawns on c4 and d5
and black had this backward pawn on e7
and Karpov used to torment his opponents
by doubling tripling up against the pawn
on e7 don't let this happen to you
you must avoid these types of positions
in this position after Bishop takes g7 I
am not happy that my opponent wants to
capture my knight so I'm going to move
my knight ah the weight is attacking my
rug so I have to move my knight to a
clever square young man
bingo that is the that is the problem
with this specific position black
recognizes that he's going to lose his
night but he does it at a in a way that
makes White's position very
uncomfortable tonight tax Queen and rook
and if the knight is captured that would
probably be dreadful dreadful dreadful
because then after King takes oops
Black has a perfect position the double
pawns probably white I think Julian
probably intended to move his clean
something like this now this is a
completely different type of a middle
game position this position I don't
think is black any problems at all the
whole difference is if this pawn were
here I would prefer white with the pawn
here I think that this position is
actually even Julian please
instead of Queen e2 could you play
Bishop c3 sure enough well I would
probably because I'm an old pawn Grover
I would probably just grab the pawn in
this position I would probably just take
your queen you would take my queen and I
would just take the pawn and I'd be a
happy camper upon ahead also I just
should mention that I do attack the
bishop in the pawn and I could play move
like rook c8 or b6 and apana it's pretty
sick yeah yeah and it's tough one can
then
oh yes just a second
the Queen was up and the night had taken
the rook oops that's not right
where are we yeah here we are to the
second it's at the top probably yeah I
take I took the rook yes in then and
then I then I played for a white take
did you see a better move instead it not
to take the rook I do take the rook okay
this is a good thing right yes yes
oh yes that's a that's that's a
possibility
ah doubled upon so that's clever that's
that's just like the move 93 that is a
very very clever question and indeed
after night G 3 there is there is
something positive about this the
question that black again it's like an
open market you know you've doubled
White's pawns which is kind of cool
right eww you messed them up but on the
other hand this pawn on g3 these double
pawns do contree they do control lots of
squares and oh I should mention probably
that I'm missing blacks best move here
that in this position okay we've seen
that after takes the rook and let's just
say for argument's sake takes the rook
takes the bishop takes the knight the
positions about even-steven right I'm
thinking that black has a possibility of
Queen g5 ooh
cream g5 so I'm threatening checkmate in
one and by the way I've got a pet theory
about chess kind of goes like this
whenever black out of the opening had
threatens a checkmate in one White has
done something wrong
whenever you allow your opponent the
opportunity to give you a checkmate in
one threat you've done something wrong
with white and I think this kind of
proves my point actually is I think that
the only move for white here if white
were to capture the knight then he would
end up with massively ugly ugly ugly
double pumps we just can't even
contemplate how terrible those pawns are
and we take the bishop so the only move
I see for white that would probably keep
him in the game
is a move like f4 and now after Queen c5
White has to go through some pretty
tricky things not to lose material rook
to F - I'll take the bishop I'll take
the bishop I'm that greedy if you take
the rook I'll take the rook with check
you'll take I'll take the bishop and
maybe you White's position is not the
best I was thinking I was thinking about
b4 yes exactly thank you I was thinking
about this move and now I'm trying to
figure out what was going on here mmm
what do you guys think about this is
this is this crazy or what should I take
the pawn on b4 okay
take the Queen so behind the idea is if
I take the rook I wanted to take this
rock but then you could take this pawn
maybe it's kind of messed up I'm not so
sure
maybe Queen g5 wasn't all yes young lady
see
Oh with the pawn on b4 yes
the discovere check is excellent I
wanted to take a look I wanted to take a
pond I wanted to do everything and the
discover check is superb the only
problem is my Queens attacked hate that
don't so we're going to go back and
we're not going to think so highly after
the move Knight d5 okay normally
speaking what's the I think Queen d2
everybody and his brother plays right
then yeah I think everybody in his
brother this is the standard move yeah
your son's not bad either Queen d2 and
now actually here again we have a kind
of a crossroads there's a group of
players who think that while Queen a5 is
okay it actually should be prefaced with
the moves a five and a four so a lot of
players you see sometimes they're
playing the moves a five a four and only
then Queen a5 another group of players
are playing the move Bishop c6 in this
exact position and their idea is
obviously to take this pawn on e4 and
what they want to do is they want to
force black to play the move f2 f3 a lot
of players in this exact position we're
going to go back just one move actually
are feeling very comfortable as black
they don't think that black has too many
problems here however they have one
nagging suspicion that with the move f2
F for their King might come under attack
so they want to even rule out the small
possibility that f4 could give white an
opportunity to seize the initiative so
that some players play
ship c6 here Queen a5 I think by far is
the most common but let's see what
happens after Bishop c6
let's just play along for a moment and
let us try to understand what it is that
black accomplishes when he provokes the
move f2 f3 we have played Bishop c6 f2
f3 we now bring our Knight to d7 well
this may and it is is not just me it is
it's kind of contrary to what a lot of
I've spoken about on on how dearly we
love our Bishop on g7 and we're not
intent on trading dark-squared bishop s'
however in this position we do it for a
very very specific reason what we're
hoping is that our queen after the
bishops get traded can come out here to
the square b6 with check and take up
residence on the c5 square that is what
black is trying to do furthermore let me
just put these moves on the board for a
moment what black is also trying to do
is remember a moment ago I was
explaining how this position should be
avoided in the sense that this pawn on
d5 is now an open rook but here the
difference is that our minor piece is
not a bishop it's actually a night and
our night on d7 has more possibilities
in the middle gained position than a
bishop on d7 for example one of the
things that we could do is black is
plate let's do it let's let's do it play
the move Queen b6 check will move the
king for just a moment and we'll play a
move like a 5 so what we're trying to do
with black is either give our knight
this very nice
outpost on c5 or in some cases move our
Knight to e5 and put pressure on this
pawn on c4 and combine it with a move a
form so this is one of the things that
and also pardon me after the move Knight
d5 I'm not forced I'm not forced to
capture this move this this piece right
away I could potentially kick the night
away for me with a movie 6 I do create a
a backward pawn on the square
d6 but I do it for very concrete
tactical reasons I think that for
example after the knight retreats I play
Queen b6 I'm in time to play rook d8 and
Knight back to f6 and keep my pawn on d6
nicely protected for those of you who
play the Hedgehog variation this is a
kind of perfect Hedgehog that black has
achieved exactly what he wants to and
traded two pairs of minor pieces while
doing it